hey what's up guys my name is asiana
welcome back to my c plus plus series
so continuing on with our journey
through data structures we're going to
be taking a look at dynamic or growable
resizable arrays whatever you want to
call them essentially the scd vector
class
that's given to us as part of the
standard template library now this is
not to be confused with a more common
mathematical term
vector which usually refers to some kind
of direction or position
in two three or four dimensional space a
vector in this sense
refers to just an array and this
actually also has a mathematical basis
where vector can also be defined
as an ordered sequence of values which
is kind of what this contiguous array
is if you're not familiar with
scd-vector i suggest that you check out
the videos that i've made on that topic
already today we're going to be taking a
look at how we can write something
similar to the scd vector class we're
going to be writing this ourselves from
scratch with the purpose of learning a
little bit more
about data structures and about how this
vector class works
and as such our goal is to essentially
replicate the behavior the same behavior
of that
std vector class so that you should be
able to more or less interchange it
we did the same thing with just the sc
array class which is like a fixed
size stuck out array check out that
video if you haven't already let's talk
a little bit about what it actually
takes to write a vector class but first
this video is sponsored by skillshare
for those of you who don't know
skillshare is a massive
online learning community where millions
of creative and curious people come
together
to take the next step in their creative
journey skillshare has thousands of
different classes for you to choose from
whether you're interested in
illustration or photography or
even just something as simple as being
productive
because who doesn't have issues with
that i really like how most of their
classes are really high quality and
they're also
nice and bite-sized meaning each little
episode or each stage of the class can
be washed
in about five minutes and coming in at
just under ten dollars a month for an
annual subscription
it's a great way to add a few more
skills into
your lives skillshare have been nice
enough to offer the first 1000 people
who sign up using the link in the
description below
two free months of skillshare premium
two months
to learn whatever you like check out the
link in description below guys
and take a look at all the different
classes that skillshare has to offer
speaking of learning
what does it actually take to write a
vector class how do we do something like
this
now personally speaking i think writing
out all of these data structures even
though they already exist and you don't
definitely need to do this to actually
write any programs
doing this is going to help you a great
deal if you're learning the language or
if you're looking at
becoming better at c plus plus the cool
thing with data structures is that they
deal
with data that's what you should be
dealing with
and thinking about when you're writing
your code and as such
even though something as simple as a
vector or an array
might seem really simple you can
actually extend it
quite a lot i mean take a look at the
standard template library code it's so
big and complex because it deals with
every little corner case
it deals really with everything and it
supports all of the newest language
features
so even if you think writing a vector
might be a little bit too simple for you
think again because i'm sure you can get
a lot
out of it i also think that a good way
to follow this series as we start
exploring more and more data structures
is to try and write it on your own pause
the video right now and try and
implement your own vector class
first think about what a vector class
actually is we'll cover that in just a
second
and try and write it out yourself and
then compare your solution
with mine that's a really good exercise
and it's also a good way
to make sure that you're actually
thinking about how to do things yourself
and learning instead of just copying
down my code and moving on with your
life
so what is this vector data structure
well i mentioned that it is a resizable
array
and that's probably the the biggest
thing to note here
but the other huge thing that i think of
when i think of the scd vector class
is that the data there is heap allocated
this is a direct contrast to what we had
with the standard array class
because that was completely on the stack
as such it was completely fixed it was
not only fixed but we had to actually
determine the size
at compile time whereas with vector
apart from being dynamic so we don't
even have to think about the size
if we don't want to although we can we
have that option to kind of
initialize it with a given size but even
so we don't have to think about the size
at compile time because
we just push back more and more data it
resizes
everything there is dynamic and runtime
that is a huge difference and because of
that there are so many reasons why you
would want to choose the array class
over the vector class because if you
don't need
heap allocations then don't use them
they're going to slow down your program
so with that in mind the core mechanics
of a vector class really are
quite simple if you think about them i
mean all we really need
is a pointer to some heap allocated
memory
that's going to be our actual data
buffer that's where we store
all of the elements inside the array and
as we keep pushing back more and more
elements we're going to get to a point
where we don't have enough
room to store our new element because
we've obviously allocated a fixed size
of memory
we can't just grow it what do we do when
we hit
that wall well it's pretty simple all we
really need to do is allocate a
new block of memory that has enough room
for this new element and possibly more
then just copy across all of our
elements from our old block of memory
into our new block of memory
and then delete the old block of memory
that's it now if i've trained you well
that might seem like a lot
i mean we're allocating this larger
block of memory we're copying across all
the elements from the old block into the
new block of memory
then freeing the old block memory that
kind of sounds not that great for
performance right
right that's why vector resizing and all
these heap allocations really aren't
great we might explore them in more
depth a little bit later i did actually
make a video about optimizing the usage
of std vector
to try and avoid these resizes because
every time we have to grow our
array we have to grow our vector that's
usually not
not not just not great for performance
and we want to avoid it especially if
our
vector happens to have a lot of elements
inside it now based on the description
that i've given now go ahead and think
about how you would implement this class
and if you're really cool maybe you'll
actually try and write it
your own way right now if you're serious
about getting better at c
plus and learning all these things then
definitely do that before you watch the
rest of
this video on top of the brief overview
that i've just given
there's a lot of optimizations and a lot
of room for optimizations for example
instead of copying across all of the
elements from the old block into the new
block
it's a lot better to try and move those
elements from the odd block into the new
block using move semantics which i also
talked about
in a recent video if you're storing a
vector of a thousand strings and you
move them instead of copying them for
example
that's going to provide a huge
performance benefit so definitely
move instead of copy in that case but
anyway as i mentioned
there are so many things we could add to
this vector class and this video will
probably be hours long
what we're going to take a look at today
is a basic implementation
with just the base features that you
would probably want to implement
first in a vector class and then in the
future we may revisit this and extend it
a little bit more with
some of the more advanced features so
without further ado let's dive in and
take a look at how we can write a vector
class
so as mentioned last time we took a look
at static arrays and this was some of
the example code that we used
to test that out i really like writing
down some example code for a class that
i'm about to write in a lot of cases
because it helps a lot with the api
design so what i'll do here is i'll
pretend that the vector class already
exists even though it doesn't
and let's go ahead and write down this
exact same example basically i'll just
call this vector
and then i'm just going to use it as i
would with a vector so i'll push back
maybe a string here called
cherno or something like that and then
of course i'll also push back
c plus plus so obviously a very basic
test here we're going to expand this api
a lot more but this is kind of like my
bare bones
vector class we should be able to just
easily create it like this with no
concept of size
and then push back at least like a
couple elements and see it hopefully
grow with that in mind now what i'm
going to do to test this out
is i'll also type in something like a
vector i'll add a third element here
because as you'll see in a minute we're
actually going to
initialize our vector to have a size of
two by default
okay so now that we have a very basic
example let's jump into this
vector.h file which is completely blank
and take a look at how we would write
this
so obviously it's going to be a
templated type here a templated class i
should say so last time when we wrote
this array class we actually kind of
made a very simple version of it
without any templates so if templates
are still something that confuse you a
little bit
it's probably worth going back to that
video and taking a look at how i
implemented array without templates
before then moving on to templates
because i think that'll probably help
you out
but since we're big boys now we're going
to just implement
a templated version of the vector class
here so obviously you need a constructor
and the primary thing that this
constructor has to do is actually
allocate some memory for us to store
now you don't necessarily have to do
this you could just say that okay if we
create an empty vector
then no memory allocation whatsoever
only when we push back that first
element we'll allocate memory
in the interest of keeping this a little
bit more simple though i am actually
going to allocate enough room for two
elements here just because this will
simplify a little bit of the whole
growing math operations that we end up
doing
so what exactly does a vector store well
an array of course
stores just a stack allocated array of
this type here
with this kind of compile time template
parameter size
whereas this is going to store instead a
pointer to whatever our type is and
we'll call this m
underscore data we'll set it equal to
null pointer by default just so that our
code is a little bit easier to debug and
then we also need to keep track of two
different size variables
we want to keep track of a variable
called size which is going to be
the number of elements that are actually
inside our vector
so in other words if we take a look at
this we'll push back one element
our size should be one two should be two
three should be three
it's going to actually keep track of how
many elements we have additionally
though we're going to store a variable
called
capacity and this is going to be how
much memory we have allocated so how
many elements worth of memory have we
actually allocated not necessarily
present inside the vector at the moment
but how much could we store without
having to reallocate
so why do we need these two variables
why not just have a size
well we could and that would be totally
fine and you could write a vector that
way it would work
the problem though is that you'll be
reallocating the memory
a lot more often if you saw just the
exact amount of memory required
to store the number of elements that are
currently inside that vector
so for example if i pushed back a lot of
these and i mean a lot
we don't want to reallocate every time
we
push back an element that's going to be
terribly inefficient
instead what we want to do is use some
kind of like growing
function essentially that's going to say
that okay well let's start for example
with a size of two
and then maybe every time we have to
reallocate
because a new element is pushed back
let's maybe double
our capacity so let's allocate enough
for four that way we don't have to
allocate again when we push the fourth
element in when we push the fifth
element in maybe it'll double again
and it'll go to eight that way these
three are going to be pushed back
no problem and then when we push back
the ninth one it'll double to 16 and so
on so forth so in other words
we'll drastically reduce the number of
reallocations we need
to ensure that we have enough storage to
store all of these elements now doubling
the capacity every time we need to
reallocate is definitely something you
could do but we're going to do something
a little bit more conservative in terms
of space what we're going to do is
add on half of the current capacity so
in other words we'll
we'll grow from two to three from three
to four from four to six
from six to nine and so on and so forth
just because it's a little bit more
conservative on memory
but this is the beauty of writing your
own data structures you can actually
easily control that
to tailor it towards a specific need in
your application maybe you know
that you're going to be pushing back a
lot of elements and you want it to be a
little bit more generous with the amount
of memory it allocates that's totally
fine
but then again keep in mind that usually
with vectors you can
actually specify an initial size or an
initial allocation
to prevent having to reallocate every
time you push back new
elements anyway back in the vector class
that's why we have these two because one
is the actual amount of elements inside
the vector
whereas the other one keeps track of our
capacity for elements how much could we
store
with our current memory allocation so
the most important function here then in
the beginning is going to be something
that i'm going to call
re-alec reallocate what this is going to
do is reallocate our memory
and it's basically got three things that
it really needs to do
let's make this a private function
because we shouldn't be calling this
outside
of this class and i'm actually going to
take in a size t
here which is going to be our new
capacity and initially i'm going to
allocate enough room for two elements
here so
what does this function need to do well
step one is
it needs to allocate a new block of
memory now a more complicated
vector implementations such as
scd-vector you have the option of
specifying a custom allocator and this
can be really useful
if you're designing a piece of software
that you really want to perform well and
maybe you're giving it an allocator that
won't necessarily hit the heap
every time it has to allocate we're not
going to bother with that with our
simple implementation here though we'll
just use the new operator
then what it needs to do is copy all of
our existing elements in our vector
over into this new block of memory
remember even though we're using this in
the constructor here where we have no
elements this could be used for resizing
from say four to six so in other words
if we push in our fifth element perhaps
we want to
resize this to a capacity of six once
we've allocated a new block of memory
which is enough
to hold all of our elements or in this
case it's going to be the size of new
capacity here
once we've done that we need to copy
across all of our old elements
into this new block of memory so that's
the next step
copy now i'm saying copy but
realistically you want to try and move
them for sure because copying them is
going to be
not only a waste of performance it's
just going to be unnecessary because
clearly
we're going to be deleting the old block
of memory which is our third step
so copy slash move alt elements into
new block this is what our reallocation
function looks like
so now let's implement it it's not going
to be too hard first i'm going to make a
t pointer here we'll call this new block
and this is going to just simply be
nu t with our new capacity simple
as that now we could use like maybe a
unique pointer here or a shared pointer
or something like that
i never like using smart pointers when
i'm kind of
this low level into things if i'm
dealing with like allocations and
custom data structures i think that
using smart pointers
is just an unnecessary layer on top of
everything else
if we're designing a data structure we
want to access memory
as low level as we can so that's why i'm
using raw pointers here so once we've
allocated this block we now need to
move everything from the old block into
the new block so to do that
we'll simply write a for loop that goes
through all of the elements
that currently exist so we can just use
m size here and we'll just
copy them across and we can do that like
this
now we are copying them currently we're
going to take a look at moving them in a
little bit so why are we written a for
loop why can't we just use mem copy
well we can't use mam copy because we
actually need to be hitting the copy
constructor of all of these elements
if we had a bunch of integers or floats
or any kind of primitive type
that's totally fine we can just use
memcopy
but for more complex types like classes
that might have
allocations of their own which the
copyconstructor will then perform a deep
copy on it it's important for us to
actually make sure that we're calling
that copy constructor otherwise our
classes and more complex types won't get
copied correctly
after we've copied everything into this
new block we can just delete
our old block which is of course called
mdata
we can then set mdata to be our new
block and finally
make sure that our capacity matches our
new capacity
size here remains intact because it's
not the responsibility of reallocation
to actually set the size it's more or
less in charge of the capacity
now there's one little flaw here and
that is that this will theoretically
only work for
growing our size if we want to downsize
our allocation from a larger
block to a smaller block it this for
loop isn't really going to work
because it of course relies on m size
being smaller
than this new capacity otherwise we're
going to overflow
our array here we can just do a little
check though to make sure that if we are
downsizing
we only copy up to new capacity size of
elements
and so to do that i'll just write a
quick if statement here that we'll just
check to see if new capacity is
less than size and if the new capacity
is less than our current size
we'll simply set size to new capacity
and make sure that we use this
size variable here now since we are
reallocating though
which means that this new block is in
fact not going to contain
m size anymore we should actually update
the size
and because of that we can simplify this
a little bit and just change it to be
m size like this so we're actually
directly going to be changing the size
of our vector
if for some reason we downsize it now
this is definitely something that you
could argue is not the responsibility of
this reality function
and i would probably agree with you but
to keep things simple we're going to
leave it like this that's it
that is our entire reallocation function
we should now be able to easily
grow or shrink our vector as needed so
now let's write a simple
pushback function now these are usually
void in the stl
i like to actually have them return the
element that we're pushing back but
again to keep things simple
we'll keep them void here so what we're
going to do here
is push back an element so how do we do
that well it's pretty simple we can just
say mdata
at m size equals value and then we
should obviously increment
size so we can either do that here or
maybe to keep things a little bit more
simple
we can do it down here this is the basic
way that we put things into an array of
course
but the problem is if we're trying to
push back an element and there's no room
for it
we need to call this really function so
to do that we simply check to see
if size is greater than or equal to the
capacity so in other words if we're at
capacity or somehow
over it then we need to reallocate with
some kind of
new capacity so to do that we'll simply
call realic
and as mentioned before what we're going
to do is we're going to take our
capacity
and add half of our capacity to it so
we're basically growing this by 1.5
times
every time we need to grow which is
effectively growing by 50
and that is it we're now copying this
element
over here which is pretty cool now
finally it's probably good to actually
see what our size is that might be
important so let's make a
size function here which just returns m
size and finally for mach 1
of this vector class we're going to add
an operator
our index operator here so that we can
actually access
our data so we'll write a const version
of this and a non-const version of this
which will simply return mdata at index
and of course
i will also write a non-const version of
this in case we actually want to use it
to modify
the value inside the array okay so
clearly there's a flaw here which is
what do we do
if we're trying to access an index
outside of the bounds of the array
typically the way that the vector class
in the stl would handle this is it would
have an assert here
if this index was greater than our size
but only in debug mode or if you've got
like
stl debugging enabled essentially so you
could do that you could just say if
index
is greater than or equal to m size then
maybe you want to like assert here or
something like that we're not going to
bother doing that here today
but that is definitely something that
you would probably want to do because if
you just simply do an assert here then
it will be stripped from release builds
anyway and you won't suffer any
performance penalties
but in debug builds you'll have that
extra debug ability and that extra
information of just knowing if you're
accidentally going outside of the bounds
of your array
anyway here is our extremely simple
vector class don't worry we're going to
improve it in a minute but i do want to
test it out here
so what i'll do is i'll add three
elements here because remember that
should trigger a reallocation
i want to quickly write a function here
though that's going to actually print
our vector now because we don't know
what type it is we'll have to make this
a template function
because of course this could be a vector
of any type so let's go ahead
and take in a const vector of t we'll
call this vector
then we'll write a for loop which goes
through all of the elements here so size
t
i equals zero i is less than vector dot
size i plus plus
and then we'll just print vector i see
out
vector i i'll also just add in a little
divider here in case we want to print
many of these at once okay cool so now
if i call print vector
with this vector let's see what we get
all right check this out so we get
churno c plus plus and vector and of
course we
we never specified a size or anything
like that our vector
seems to work let's go ahead and just
add vector a few more times
as a basic test and of course here it is
it works
fine if we put a little break point over
here just so that we can
see where our vector is at we can see
that we have a size of eight a capacity
of nine of course because it went from
six to nine
and everything seems pretty good to me
okay
so let's talk a little bit about this
whole copying thing and also write a new
function called in placeback
which is a very very useful function to
have inside our vector class what i'll
do to demonstrate this is i'll simply
write a struct here called vector3
just going to be like a mathematical
kind of three component vector here
xyz we're going to write a constructor
here that takes in
well let's write a default constructor
that does nothing maybe i'll initialize
these to zero just to be nice here then
i'm going to write just a scalar
constructor
that sets each of these to whatever the
scalar is set to in fact i might just
drop this down here
to make it a little bit easier to read
so we'll do x
y z is set to the scalar and then
finally we'll also write a constructor
here that just
takes in x y and z and just sets that up
okay cool so the point of this is of
course to write a copy constructor here
which obviously isn't necessary for this
class but the reason we're doing this is
so that we can actually see
when our vectors are being copied so
we'll just say copy
and we'll of course need to actually
copy our data and i'll also write a
destructor here which is going to say
destroy and then
finally i'll write a move constructor
here so now of course we should be able
to detect copies
moves and destroys which is pretty cool
last thing we're kind of missing is the
constructor but we won't worry about
that
so let's change this over to actually be
our vector so we now have a vector of
vector threes
i'm gonna go ahead and create some of
these so maybe one of these
will be a scalar i'll i'll remove some
of these just to make this less complex
one of them will take in xyz here
and then one of them maybe will just be
a default constructor so we have three
of these let's hit a five and see what
we get now in my haste here i of course
didn't actually provide any assignment
or move operators so let's quickly do
that and now with these two assignment
operators present let's hit a five
we need to also make sure that we print
vector3 correctly because there's no way
to just print it like a string like this
so to make that happen we'll just copy
and paste this and write a
specialization
for our templated print function here
that just takes in a vector
of vector threes specifically and we'll
print x y
and z okay cool now if we hit a five
everything should work and of course we
need to make sure
that this print vector function is
actually underneath this struct
declaration
otherwise it has no idea what a vector
three is okay let's hit a five
everything should now finally work
all right so we have a lot of stuff
happening here we have a copy we have a
destroy we have a copy copy destroy
destroy copy destroy
lots of stuff going on but finally of
course we get this result now
this whole next step of this video is
going to be all about
reducing these copies and destroys
because we just simply don't need to be
doing
so many copies every time we want to do
this in fact you can see we're pushing
back three different vectors
we're actually copying this four times
now for a vector i want to stress that
this
there's nothing really you can do about
that and it's also not something that's
even worth optimizing because this
is just simply three floats copying
three floats which is 12 bytes of memory
is never really a problem you would
probably never want to optimize that
but just think of vector 3 as
potentially a string or something that
might actually have a heap
allocation every time we do copy we have
to
reallocate that heap memory somewhere
else and then
free the old one this is obviously not
very good for performance
and there are ways to improve that and
that's what this is going to be about
so first step you'll notice here that
all of these are actually temporaries
these are not variables that exist
elsewhere and then finally we're
deciding to push them back into a vector
no the only reason they're here is
because we want to basically give them
to the vector
so one thing that we could do is write a
different pushback function
that actually takes in a temporary so if
we say t
ampersand ampersand to create an r value
reference
what we can now do is effectively the
same thing here
except instead of just simply assigning
mdata to value
we're going to actually move it in there
now move just simply
casts this value to be an r value
reference you can see it's already an r
value reference
but there's a bit of a trick which is as
soon as you actually enter a function if
it's a parameter like this
this now becomes an l value and since
it's an l value we need to be like no
no i want this to be an r value
seriously for the purposes of moving
this in here
so now if this if this overload is used
which it will be for all of these cases
because they're all
r values we should not see any copy
coming from this actual pushback
function it should be moving it and if
you're confused about l values and r
values as well as move semantics all
that i have a bunch of videos about that
i'll link them in the top right corner
definitely check them out let's see what
we get here so now you can see we have
move destroy
copy copy destroys remove destroy so
this is much better now we're doing
moves instead of copies every time we
push back
an element however when we need to
reallocate our vector
we're going back and copying that so how
do we fix that
well pretty simple if we go back to
vector.h
inside this really function where i said
we should probably move this
we can just say that well hey let's cast
this to be an r value reference
and try and move it because guess what
if there's no move constructor for this
type
it is just gonna copy it so everything
will be safe here and obviously for
primitive types like
integers and floats and whatever it's
not gonna do anything really so there's
really no downside to just
making this move if able to especially
because obviously in this case we are
actually trying to move it we know that
the old data is about to be deleted if
this was actually supposed to be a copy
we would obviously not want to move it
let's hit f5 okay look at that amazing
no more copies now
we're just moving our data across great
but what about in place back well and
place back is a little bit of a special
function that exists inside the std
vector class and it's really really
useful
what it does is it basically says that
well instead of constructing this
vector3 instance over here inside the
stack frame of main
and then moving it into that data
storage we have inside
vector which is what we're currently
doing why don't you just give me all of
the arguments that you that i need to
actually construct a vector3
and i'll do the construction right there
in place in my data block that's what in
placeback does
so in other words if we were to rewrite
this to be in place back
it would just not take this in at all it
would literally just
take a list of arguments in so it would
look something
like this and for this one well it would
just
look like nothing at all it wouldn't
take any arguments because we want to
construct it with a default constructor
so how do we make
this work well we have to use variatic
templates which of course are everyone's
favorite templates who gets confused by
those am i right but in all seriousness
is really not that difficult what we'll
do here
is we'll write a template which takes in
a
variable number of args which we will
call args because that's a good name for
it
we'll actually return a t reference here
because since we're constructing
something in place it's not really that
easy for us to get that object back
so usually these functions return a t
reference i'll call it in place back of
course and now we'll just take
in all of our arguments here now i might
make a video in the future about
variatic templates and when i do i'll
expand a lot more on them because
honestly they definitely
fill up a video so we'll make sure that
we have our same reallocation behavior
and then we'll do m data m size equals t
so we're constructing a t here and what
we'll do
is forward all of our arguments to the
constructor but we're going to
add a little triple dot here to actually
unpack these arguments because we
basically want to now say that okay all
these variatic template arguments that
we've passed over here
i want to expand them so that t gets the
correct argument so for example with 2 3
4 i would expect to get three floats
like that
and that's what we'll get and of course
if we specify something like two floats
something that isn't compatible with a t
constructor
it's not going to work and it will just
give us a compile error
okay that's actually it let's not forget
a semicolon here and you can see that
our code looks like it compiles
let's hit f5 now we get a build error
because it looks like i have just
not called my variable with the right
name and of course we forgot to actually
return this so how we're going to return
this we'll simply return
m data at m size not forgetting to
increment our size
because of course we have just added
something to our array
or to our vector all right so there you
go we have move destroy move move
destroy the destroyers are happening
because we're actually releasing the old
variables the old vector 3
instances when we actually move them but
otherwise
this is now looking pretty cool and
we're constructing all of our memory in
place which of course
is great now the last thing i'm going to
show you in this extremely long video
now
is what happens when we have to destroy
everything
well of course in the destructor we just
need to make sure that we simply delete
mdata it's as simple as that make sure
you use the
array deletion operator here to make
sure that it both deletes the entire
block
of memory as well as actually calls the
destructor of each element here
now this in itself by the way is
slightly difficult
because at the moment we're not holding
actual pointers so if we were
holding actual pointers it would be in
it would be important for you to
actually delete
each and every pointer there if you
allocate memory every time you in place
back or push back
however if you've used a vector class
before you know this isn't the
responsibility of the vector class
if you create a vector with a bunch of
pointers which you allocate and then
transfer ownership to the vector class
is your responsibility still to delete
them so this is not something
that the vector class should be handling
therefore this is
totally fine speaking of calling the
destructor what if we don't want to
delete this data block what if we simply
want to resize it
by using a function such as pop back in
that case what exactly happens well
obviously size goes down as long as size
is greater than zero we don't want to
actually do any kind of resizing if
we're at zero there's nothing to pop
back
but the other important thing that we
need to actually do here
is called the destructor and so to do
that after we
actually reduce the size we'll say m
data at m size which
should still be a valid element of
course will explicitly call the
destructor like so
this will effectively nullify our object
and release any resources that it might
own
because from this point forward you
should no longer
have any kind of reference to t now
there is
you you should not you should never have
any kind of reference to this
and then finally since we're on a roll
of deleting things here let's also write
a clear function
this is going to do the same thing as
pop back essentially and you could just
have a while loop that just pops back
until size is zero but what i'm going to
do is just take the more simple approach
write a for loop which calls the
destructor
of every single element here and then
i'm going to set size to zero
and there we go so let's let's try this
out now let's go back to main
i'm going to add maybe a few more
vectors here which i'll kind of
randomize a little bit here just to have
something a little bit more interesting
and then what i'll do is i'll pop back a
few of these so maybe let's do pop back
in the middle here
let's pop back two things then let's
maybe
clear this then let's maybe
you know in place back these two again
i'll add some print vectors
basically everywhere here so that we can
see what happens
after all of these stages let's hit f5
okay well we didn't crash that's good
news
let's take a look at what happened here
because there's a lot of stuff moved
forward don't really care about those
things too much we have our one one
one which is our scalar constructor here
two three four one three four and our
empty vector that looks good
then we print it then we've popped back
two elements here which we've
destroyed both of we're then printing
our vector which as you can see gives us
these two again because those are the
ones that remain inside the vector we're
then in placing back two more elements
here
and of course here they are added at the
end of our vector we're then doing a
clear which is destroying all of these
four vectors that we have here and then
finally we're doing a move destroy move
destroy as we
push back two more elements there they
are and then we're actually printing
that vector
twice now these move destroyers here
from the place back are actually coming
from this function itself because you
can see that it's actually constructing
a temporary here which is then moving
into here and we can of course check
that if we hit f5 and take a look at
this
f10 is is doing a move destroy as you
can see
now technically if you're a keen
observer you may
in fact deduce that well is that any
better than this pushback
r-value reference function because isn't
it just doing a move
at the end of the day anyway even if it
is in fact constructing the object
in this stack frame instead of the main
one and
you would be correct how would you solve
that leave a comment below this is
like a little bit of an advanced
exercise perhaps and the answer of
course is well i want to construct my
object
i just want to do it in place of this
actual memory
now this memory exists we know that it
exists because we've actually allocated
that memory
so now it's a matter of well instead of
constructing this object on the stack in
a place back and then moving it into
mdata storage
how about you just construct it inside m
data so how do we construct things in
place
well we can actually use the placement
new operator
now and you might be scary here because
you might associate that with heap
allocations
but if you use a placement new you're
providing the actual memory for the
object to be constructed in which is
obviously coincidentally exactly what we
want here so what we can do
is actually grab the memory address of
this element because this is where it's
supposed to live
and then simply forward these arguments
into that constructor not forgetting the
actual type
that we're trying to construct so as
simple as
that and by doing this if we pop a
breakpoint here and relaunch this
we have nothing in our console at the
moment let's hit f10 we have nothing in
our console so
no moves have been done and no destroys
have been done
how cool is that let's hit f5 check this
out everything still works everything
looks a lot tidier of course it still
needs to move and destroy
when we actually reallocate but that's
it
look how clean this looks now so that is
the advanced
tip of the day don't forget about
placement new for constructing objects
in place now even though we've spent
quite a long time writing this vector
class here today and i hope that this
was helpful to you
there are still so many things that one
would want to add to this class
such as probably the number one thing
being arrays how do i remove elements
from this well
you can't at this stage and that's why
even though this reallocation function
technically supports shrinking
we're not shrinking anywhere and in
addition to that what if i want to
in place an element or push an element
into the middle of the vector
what do i do there that's also something
that you would probably want to
implement although keep in mind that if
you're trying to replace things and
remove things from the middle of vectors
maybe you don't want to use a vector
data structure because of course the
memory has to be contiguous
and therefore you'll trigger potentially
a reallocation or at the very least
having to shift and move all those
elements down
to make up for the gap or the extra
space that you've created and then also
we would probably want iterators so
there are still a number of things we
would want to discuss
perhaps we'll cover them in a later
episode of this c
plus series but there you have it a
basic implementation of
our vector class haha did you think that
was
it there is a glaring flaw that i have
left in this vector class
if anyone knows what it is please leave
a comment below and if in fact if it was
up to me i'd probably end the episode
here
and have like it to be continued thing
and leave this all on you
but i of course don't want to publish a
video with with bugs in the code i've
written
so i am going to address this now the
problem
has to do with how we allocate and
deallocate memory
specifically the problem lies in this
delete
call over here and also potentially in
this delete call here
as you know we're manually calling the
destructor in both the pop back and the
clear function
which is you know i mean a lot of care
needs to be taken when you're manually
calling the destructor because the worst
thing that can happen is
the delete function also calls a
destructor and for a type like vector3
here
that's not really going to do any harm
however let's make vector3
a little bit more of a complex type
let's go ahead and just
add some kind of you know memory block
into
this vector3 class i'll go down here
into
the constructor in fact into all of the
constructors now i'll just make it so
that we allocate maybe like
five integers or whatever on the heap so
basically we've created a memory block
that we now need to deallocate
i'll add this exact code into everywhere
else i'm not going to bother formatting
this code or anything like that
you need to make sure that in the copy
constructor we actually copy it i'm not
going to bother with that because we're
not actually calling the copy
constructor anywhere but in our move
constructor what we will do is just make
sure
that our memory block is going to just
be equal to other memory blocks so we're
stealing that pointer and then setting
other memory blocks to be null
we'll need to make sure that we write
this code otherwise it's going to be our
folder nothing works
and we'll do the same thing for the move
assignment operator and again the copy
assignment operator and copy constructor
just simply aren't called anywhere else
and in fact to simplify that and to make
sure that is the case i'm just going to
make sure that i actually delete
both of them so that we're sure that
we're never accidentally copying
anything
so now what we've got is a move
constructor that properly moves that
memory block and our general
constructors i forgot one here the
default one
that allocates this memory block finally
we're going to deallocate it
so delete it inside the destructor this
is the proper
usage of this class if it was to have a
memory block this is totally fine we can
set it to nonpointer if we want
by default but you can see every
constructor initializes it anyway
so now that we've got this let's
surround our vector
in a little bit of a scope technically
we don't have to do this it should crash
anyway
but just to be safe when we get to the
end of this
scope and our stack allocation for
vector is over it's going to try and
delete this
so this is in fact going to call
operator delete on the memory block
inside the vector class and inside the
vector3 class
sorry for picking such confusing names
vector and vector3
mybad it's going to try and delete that
memory block this is going to prove
slightly problematic because we've
popped back
and cleared and done various other
things so let's hit f5
okay look at that we get an error and if
we kind of drill down here a little bit
it's because we're trying to delete a
memory block and the problem will be
that this is a memory block that has
already been deleted we can also
try and simplify this a little bit just
to pinpoint the problem
exactly if i just do a couple of in
place backs here with nothing really too
scary
it's going to work fine we're not going
to get any crashes but when we start to
actually play around with it a little
bit and especially with pop back because
we've called the destructor
of vector 3 which has in fact deleted
this over here
then what happens when we call this
we're going to land in a world of hurt
so how do we get around this well we
still have to call the destructor here
there's no real way around that
what we need to do instead is change the
way that we allocate
and de-allocate memory so specifically
vector destructor is going to call clear
which of course is going to go through
everything
and manually call the destructor so now
what we need to do
is the new and delete operators that we
use
we instead want to use versions that do
not call the constructor
or destructor so how do we do that well
keep
in mind this is there shouldn't be any
constructors being called here at all
anyway so there's no point at which we
need to call a constructor
all we need to do here is essentially
just malloc enough memory
to fill up this new capacity so how do
we do that well we're not actually going
to use mallet because we're using
c plus plus instead we're going to use
operator new i'm just going to put into
the global namespace like this to make
sure it works properly
so operator new and then into here we
need to provide
the amount of space that we want to
allocate so how many bytes do we want to
allocate
well this is going to be new capacity
times the size of
our type that we're actually storing
like that this is going to return
void so we need to make sure in c plus
to cast it to a t
pointer same with delete instead of
calling delete like this
we're actually going to call operator
delete and i'll just
put that global namespace operator at
the front there we're going to delete
our data block and then we also need to
specify the size of
memory that we're deleting which of
course will be our existing capacity
times the size of t now since we're
deleting here we're not actually calling
the destructor on all of those old
elements
so that is something that we need to do
keep in mind that we have actually
moved them across into this new block
now so it should be safe to call the
destructor on those
so i'll go through size once again worth
noting here that it should be our
original size in the case of shrinking
but this isn't something we're going to
talk about today because we don't have
shrinking and all we're going to do is
into m data i i just want to basically
call the destructor this is kind of like
doing a clear acceptation clear on mdata
in fact i think
clear does exactly what we want i mean
it also sets the size to zero
so to make this a little bit more simple
we could just call clear like that
everything is safe in the new block
anyway and now that we've done that we
of course reassigned data and
new capacity the only thing that that
clear has actually done is also set our
size to zero
which is slightly problematic i'm
actually going to go back on that i'm
actually just going to copy this
and replace it with clear here just that
we leave our size intact
and that should be the end of this new
realic function and finally of course
with this delete up here instead of
doing that kind of array delete operator
there we're going to call
operator delete mdata and then m
capacity time size of t
this will not call any destructors clear
is what we'll go through and call
all of the destructors so now if we go
back to our original scenario let's hit
f5 and hopefully we won't get any
crashes
and you can see our program runs
successfully no crashes whatsoever we're
still firing the destructor
wherever we need and that should
emphasis on should
be bug free so that now hopefully is
our more or less proper implementation
of
a basic vector class kudos to those of
you who picked up
on that bug since we're already here and
this video is already way too long
let's quickly do a test of this vector
on primitive types this is also a really
useful thing to add to your test i'll
say like int vector or something like
that
just because when you're working with
class types it's sometimes easy to
forget things like maybe
integers don't have destructors and well
they don't but this was this code will
still work because
they have like a default there's a whole
thing about it which we're not going to
get into today but if i push back like
five or maybe like in place back like
something else
you know let's maybe uh add enough to
cause a reallocation let's try and do
a pop back like that and maybe also a
clear and this would this is just
another little test
to make sure that everything does in
fact run and compile correctly when
we're dealing with integers
since integers are easy to also kind of
print we can chuck in a little print
vector
in vector like that and our template
function should take care of that let's
check it out
and there we go we have our integers
here and here everything
seems to be running well so that is
hopefully the end of the vector class
for now congratulations if you made it
this far
anyway i hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button as i said there are
so many more features i would want to
add to this class such as the erase
function but also iterators we haven't
covered iterators
yet i'm going to make a video on that
very soon in the future and once we do
i want to revisit both the array class
and this class to make it work with
things like
range based for loops but anyway i hope
this video was helpful and that you
learned something new
let me know in the comments below how
writing your own implementation of this
went and how it compared to the solution
that i gave
here and if you're feeling like doing
some bonus work definitely
take a look at implementing both the
erase function
as well as the whole iterator situation
and if you want to go even beyond that
then take a look at the stl version of
the vector class
and see what what that has that we're
missing here and try and implement some
of those features thank you guys for
watching don't forget to check out your
two months of free skillshare premium
using the link in the description below
and i will see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you